joining us now with reaction is the man
challenging Governor Brown California
GOP gubernatorial candidate John Cox mr.
Cox thanks so much for being here
tonight we appreciate it
Thank You Katie great to be with you so
how do you explain this anarchy in
California it seems like things are
falling apart at the seams
the government in Sacramento is being
pushed back on rightfully by these local
communities how are you going to change
this if you win the governorship
I applaud Orange County I applaud in my
home county of San Diego for standing up
against this I mean this is typical of
the politicians who are running this
state into the ground Katie their first
job ought to be to keep the residents of
this state safe I'm getting involved I'm
leading the charge to to talk to other
counties as well around the state about
standing up for this because the voters
elect their county and state officials
to protect them that's the first run the
first job of government is to do that
and and and the idea that Jerry Brown
picks Easter weekend to pardon people
that have committed crimes and would let
out of jail very recently Katie Wright
isn't like these are these are people
that serve their time 30 years ago and
have been upstanding members of the
community quite the contrary these lot
of these crimes were committed in 2003
2004 2005 and yeah and they've recently
gotten out of jail I mean they're a
threat to the community and they're
they're illegal aliens and and the
government in this state ought to act to
protect the people of this state I'm a
businessman just like President Trump I
solve problems I think the president's
trying to say you know you talk about
speaking to all these voters in
California but clearly they're electing
people who believe in these sanctuary
city policies so when you're traveling
around to certain parts of California
what are you hearing directly from
people on the ground there what are they
saying to you about these things vary
laws and no polling shows that
Californians don't want to be a
sanctuary state however these
politicians keep getting reelected in
these blue counties to pass laws that
make it easy for criminals and violent
people to get away from law enforcement
well the people are rising up
I applaud the mayor of Escondido sama
Betty is a friend of mine the people are
making their their voices known to this
Katie
their concern I mean look at what Kate
Steinle --zz parents went through
there's a young woman in Sonoma County
that's dead because the sheriff there
didn't inform ice when they released a
dangerous person out into the population
I mean this can't happen the people of
this state have been beaten down by the
majority party in this state we have the
highest poverty rate we have more people
on welfare than any other state in the
country our business climate is
horrendous our quality of life is
suffering Katie where we're 50th out of
50 for crying out loud I think the
people are gonna rise up and and
continue this backlash all the way
through November they want better
management they're gonna get it I'm
gonna change this state with you if you
win if you win which it would be nice
for a Republican to win in that stage
has given the track record of Democrats
for the last couple of decades what
exactly are you planning to do to work
and with the federal government
government to reverse this trend of
criminal aliens operating in California
cartel members operating in cities
across that state how are you going to
actually approach that not from a
talking points perspective but from an
actual managerial perspective of
changing that perspective I'm gonna be
meeting with every law enforcement
agency in the state about working
together that's what people do when they
vote right absolutely they want our
public officials to work together
federal and state hand-in-glove I'm
gonna do that as the governor of this
state and I think that's what the people
want they don't want all this anger and
resentment stirred up they want the law
enforced it's the rule of law that makes
this state this state and this country
different Katie you know that yeah
absolutely well John Cox thank you very
much